e
okay and we'll call the uh exec session
of the finance committee to
order and we see we have some
Replacements if you would please
introduce yourself represent luno Dave
luno from the education committee and
for judge huitt for replacing judge
huitt over here I'm Connie Lane I'm on
the election law committee and I'm
replacing Tom
buo okay that's so the clerk can find
out Joe representative Alexander from
the special committee on housing and
Judiciary so happy to be here thank you
replacing Keith Earth and we've switched
represent Mooney over here so she can do
the Green
Sheet all right right so um I think
we're awaiting an amendment on 318 which
was the first bill on our schedule today
but we'll come back to that when the am
when the amendment is available I'll
recognize representative
leean thank you Mr chairman House Bill
10:05 relative to judicial training I'd
like to recognize representative Maguire
itl
motion of second for itl Is there
further discussion on the bill should I
explain go ahead so um this bill has
been completely uh included in what
we'll see in a house bill
318 the sponsor of this bill is upset
because because it's becoming itl and
and she's worried that if 318 doesn't
pass then this this policy will not
happen but in our
you the reverse is more likely that that
that as a separate bill this policy is
less attractive than the bail reform
policy is to both us and the Senate and
the governor and so we think this is by
including this in 318 it's more likely
to happen and more likely to happen
quickly so this bill is now
unnecessary further
discussion repres on a hold thank you Mr
chair so if we're iing 105 and including
the information in 318 will the blurb
state that clearly whoever writes the
blurb he says
discussion seeing none if you're ready
for
the U motion to
itl by representative
Maguire seconded by representative
Sweeney on House Bill
10005 the clerk will call the role on
that
motion when you're
ready
represent Mooney will be called first
very
good all right representative
Mooney
yes uh representative Maguire yes
representative Petri vs yes
representative Trace oh I did it Emer
yes
anyway representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
Representative
hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative camell yes
representative papichi Muller yes
representative walner
yes representative Lehman
yes representative
luno
yes
just okay representative Heath yes
making me lose my here representative
Murray
yes representative evil yes
representative tki
yes represent haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham
yes represent grassy
yes uh representative
Alexander yes
and representative wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 24 to1 in
favor of the
motion all right will there be a
Minority Report
sure all right who's who's doing it
yes all right and I'm I'm sorry sorry Mr
chair what's what's the uh what's the
motion
it OTP for the minority oh oh for the
minorities OTP very good thank
you all right representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman Senate Bill
252 relative to the release of a
defendant pending trial directing the
establishment of an electronic
monitoring program for criminal
defendants released on bail and making
an appropriation there of I'd like to
recognize representative McGuire thank
you m Mr chairman so
um this also is is completely um the
policy in it is completely into house
bill
318 um and so I'm going to move
itl um we deliberately decided to make a
house bill the final bill of this uh
bail stuff because we wanted it it's
it's complicated ated and it's and we're
making a new bill that combines a bunch
of other bills so we wanted it to have
its public hearing over in the Senate
rather than if we if we we could have
used this bill as the vehicle but then
it would have been just Committee of
conference type stuff so so this way
it's it'll be the house bill that
becomes the final bill so I'm moving
itl motion for Senate Bill 252 is
inexpedient to legislate further
discussion from the committee
members
seeing
none are you ready for the
question clerk will call a roll on the
motion of any expedient to legislate on
one5 252 Senate Bill 2 excuse me we
already did that next one on the list
that we're calling the role on is it
motion of itl on Senate Bill 252 clerk
will call the role for that
motion thank Commission chairman um
represent Mooney yes represent Maguire
yes represent Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative
uh yeah Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes I'm sorry I I
didn't hear that yes thank
you representative Sweeny yes
representative camell yes represent
papovich Muller yes representative
repres representative uh Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
torski yes representative hen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
priest
yes representative Alexander
yes representative wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 25 to Z in
favor of the motion all right this will
have to go on the regular calendar
because it has had money in it but I
would hope we can do this with just uh
pis or maybe even no discussion
any objection to
right all right representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1577 relative to digital images of
Ballance like to recognize
representative
cells thank you Mr chair I'd like to
move House Bill
that
discussion comments repres represent
McGuire thank you so the amendment
actually has my name on it so I probably
should talk about it um it so this bill
um came this is a bill to uh
allow the uh digital images captured by
the new style of voting machines which I
believe four Towns now have um to be
viewed by members of the public and so
um the the main problem with the
original bill is that it had
um it it had a significant cost because
the way the viewing was imagined was
that an employee of the secretary of
state would conduct sort of viewing
sessions and any interested people could
come to the viewing session and they
would display it and so on so it
required an employee
uh this amendment removes the cost from
the bill and it it it just um
allows uh towns which is where the data
is to sell copies of those images to
anyone who wants them for their costs so
so there's no more you know viewing
sessions no more extra employee and and
therefore no more
cost thank you further discussion
representative able yes thank you very
much Mr chair I'll be supporting the
amendment but I'll be voting um against
the bill as amended I did have an
opportunity to speak with uh our deput
deputy secretary of state this morning
about the amendment um their office
continues to appros hb1
1577 for uh the reasons that we heard in
the division one of which is that that
they're uh continue to be concerned
about potential vote buying schemes um
that could stem from the viewing of the
ballots because they're concerned that
the ballots could be marked in some way
to indicate to somebody whether somebody
voted the way they wanted them to and
the other thing that they mentioned um
in the division that they continue to be
concerned about is the privacy of uh
folks using the um accessibility
machines so um for that reason there
were SE several others um I I'll be
supporting the amendment but opposing
the Bill thank you representative
hle thank you Mr Speaker um the concerns
regarding buying votes are probably
overstated today everybody walks around
with a a portable cell phone with a
camera and can easily take an image they
can take an image even including their
driver's license if necessary to show
evidence that they have voted a certain
way vote buying is illegal it's already
prohibited by Statute either we believe
that statute works or we don't if
someone wanted to do it today the means
exist today this just allows everybody
else to verify the counts and to make
sure their vote was in the list of
ballots that was counted I think we all
should support this thank
you further
discussion represent
cell thank you Mr chair just a point of
order um I didn't hear a second on my
motion I wanted to make sure that you
had received a second I'll
second have a couple of
choices I guess we'll say representative
Griffin second the motion on the
amendment all right without objection if
we can do it with a show of hands on the
adoption of the amendment the house bill
1577 all those in favor of the amendment
that has has been discuss please raise
your
opposition none all right motion is
adopted now we moved on to House Bill
1577 the motion is ought to pass as
amended by the amendment we have just
heard
discussed okay further discussion on the
amended seeing none the motion is ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1577
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative Mooney yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative emck yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
papovich Muller yes represent walner
no Representative leean no
representative Lan no representative Lon
no representative Heath no
representative Murray no Representative
eil no Representative tki no
representative haen Phillips no
represent Stringham no represent grassy
no represent Pierce PR
no representative Alexander
yes representative uh Wilder
yes Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12 in
favor of the
motion okay well there'll be a Minority
Report on
1577 yes there will sir thank you very
much I'll write it representative eel
yes and
eel the motion was itl oh no the mo 1577
is out to pass minity Minority Report
minor
BB all
right I have a note here from uh Paul
Smith the clerk saying if we itl a bill
with a fiscal note then there's no money
in it it can go on the consent calendar
so we have a couple of them there that
you can change to
consent
it yes there's an itl y all right have
Amendment passed out for House Bill
1589 which is the next one once you have
it in place I'll ask representative
Maguire to introduce the
amendment uh yes uh thank you Mr
chairman I'll I'll move ought to pass
1396 so um this bill creates uh uh
veterans courts which are similar to
drug courts um the numbers we got from
it was that the estimate was maybe um 26
27 individuals a year would would end up
using them um and so we used as kind of
a you know an upper limit uh the number
of 40 and the way the the original bill
was written was the cost was going to be
a flat two million dollars a year of
payments from the state to
counties um
Modified by the size of the county so
the smallest counties would get the
least and the biggest counties would get
the most but it was still I mean $2
million a year for for um 40 cases Max
we thought was was way Overkill so so
what this bill does is instead
substitutes a a kind of carrot for the
counties to implement veterans courts of
$5,000 per case and and it also includes
a maximum of um uh well it would be a
maximum of $200,000 a year there is also
an employee here I believe which is a
kind of a veterans court um uh
administrator of some kind so um so the
total cost in this bill is
163,000 but that's because it's a half
years's amount so um the the you know if
it's actually
only 26 cases a year then the the cost
would go down
correspondingly Motion in a second on
Amendment 1396 further discussion
representative
Griffin do you have your hand
up and indicating you were second in
okay further discussion seeing none
without objection if we could all show
amendment
I think it's everybody representative
Stringham was a little late but I think
you're in favor all right motion is
adopted uh unanimously to adopt the
amendment the motion before us now is a
to pass as amended House Bill 1589 by
Amendment 1396 is is there any further
discussion you see the the motion is by
representative Maguire second by
representative
Griffin further discussion I see none
the clerk will call a rooll on the
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
1589 as amended by Amendment
1396 thank you Mr chairman
representative Mooney yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri vote
Yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeny yes
representative Campell yes represent
Popovich Muller yes representative
walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes representative torski yes
representative haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassie yes representative priest
yes representative Alexander yes
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vot is 25 to Z in favor of the motion
all right I'm hoping this can uh go
without debate but we'll have just a pi
required moving on
318 okay moving on to
um House Bill 1633 and recognized
represent
Lehman thank you Mr chairman uh 1633
relative to the legalization and
regulation of cannabis and making
Appropriations
therefore I'd like to recognize
representative grassy
for a motion
and Mr chairman I'll move out to pass
with
Amendment okay representative grassie
moves who was the
second Sweeny the dynamic duo ought to
would you like to explain the changes in
okay there there there just a few
changes in the bill but uh this is
pretty much the bill that came out of
Commerce Committee
um if you want me to go through and tell
you exactly what the changes are I I
probably can't right off the top of my
head but i' defer to the chairman of the
committee all right representa Lehman is
recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh so
representative grassy is correct we
pretty much stuck with the U version
that came out of the Commerce Committee
I know you all were aware of a lot of
back and forth and suggestions that uh
we accept some language that was
suggested to us by a member of the
Senate but we did stick with the house
version the key issues that we added or
if you will changed uh the fiscal
committee will have General oversight of
any transfers over $75,000
U the fiscal committee will also receive
quarterly updates on the progress as
this moves forward the Commerce
Committee will also receive the same
reports uh liquor funds will be used the
fund cannabis versus General
funds and finally all funds received by
the Cannabis commission will go to the
general funds we don't anticipate any
funds from this passage of this bill for
at least two years so I think that
pretty much covers it Mr chairman and it
was a 10% on it rather than 12 and a
half that's correct
amended did we vote on the amendment
already no all right all in favor of the
hand
I think we see 23
24 all right the am amendment is adopted
how many was
opposed one two three four must have
been 20 20 to five 20 to
five um motion is adopted motion before
us now is ought to pass as amended by
house bill by house by Amendment 1393 on
House Bill
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
1633 thank you Mr chairman
representative
Mooney
no
representative Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin
no represent of
bean
yes Representative hle
no representative Sweeney
yes represent cambrell
no represent papovich Muller
yes representative walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes I'm
sorry yes thank
you representative Tori
yes represent haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent
grassie yes representative priest yes
yes representative Alexander
yes representative wer
no Mr chairman the vote
is let me see
18-6 that that can't be right
19 oh I'm sorry
I all right it is
19 is your normally I see yours top 19
to
six is correct uh I will be writing The
Minority
Report okay have we got the amendment
yet
the amendment 318 is being printed um
should have it shortly all right we'll
come back to that later as it's
available and we'll move on to division
two and I recognize representative Emer
on House Bill
1202 thank you Mr chair House Bill 1202
is relative to the issuance of permits
for the alteration of driveways exist
exiting onto public ways and since my
running back isn't there I'll keep the
ball
myself uh Department of Transportation
came to us uh with a a plea because the
idea is that uh curb cuts on state roads
are taking exceptionally long time to
get
approved idea behind a more rapid
approval is if a developer is putting in
apartment building we want to get it
approved so we can have additional
Living Spaces as soon as
possible uh I I think the the uh
Department of Transportation kind of put
a rope around their neck they asked for
three additional
people uh and we agreed but they if if
it is not done in a timely fashion the
curb cut is approved without Department
of
Transportation U that that's where we
are and and we supported it so hopefully
amendment goes the committee in an
amendment right I don't
was hack and Phillips yeah there was an
amendment it was
um 20 I'm sorry 202 24-
0945 um repres representative Alexander
co-sponsored or I guess sponsored it um
so it was just a small change my
understanding um it was a technical
change referencing the correct paragraph
uh which was incorrectly mentioned
before so um it was a minor adjustment
and I think the committee 90 voted to
approve it okay who can we put down from
the committee that uh that made the
motion to adopt the amendment I'm happy
to do it I
don't all right represent hacken
Phillips Phil okay 2304 was the
amendment
who
three two Z to four so the last four
digits was
0945 is the amendment and who second
hacken Phillips seconded by
M yeah 2024 is obvious of the year so
all right
0945 Mr chair
sorry sorry uh if division two recalls
representative Alexander did bring the
committee amendment in or an amendment
in his name we did redraft it in
representative emer's name so I don't
know if you want to use that one to
bring to the floor with a a committee
member's name as a sponsor or that's up
to
you do you have that number yeah it was
0971 H is the amendment and I don't know
if the committee doesn't have it I can
say say the number of the amendment
again 0 971 yes 971
okay it is the same language as the
Alexander Amendment just the sponsor
switched sponsor all right representa
Emer your decision on who makes the
motion in the second on the amendment I
I'll make the motion on the amendment
seconds okay everyone familiar with what
the amendment does all
in question representative
Edwards I I don't I don't have a problem
voting on
0971 I'm just looking at our notes oh
there it is it now says 0971 I'm I'm in
sync now sorry all
right any objection to adoption by show
of hands all right all in favor raise
your
hand I don't see any objection hands
down any opposed looks like 25 to
nothing all
right motion before us now is ought to
pass on House Bill 122 as amended by
Amendment
0971 further discussion represent be
your GL on want to say anything okay if
there's no further discussion CL will
call a rooll on the motion of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill
1202 thank you Mr chairman
representative Mooney
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeny yes
representative Camrose yes represent
papich Muller yes representative walner
yes represent Lehman yes representative
Lane yes representative luno yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray
yes represent Vil yes represent torski
yes represent haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes representative
grassy
no representa Priest
No representative Alexander
yes and representative wer yes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 23-2 in
favor of the
motion okay and that will go on the
regular
okay all right and that's uh represent
emmer will will write the
report you can hold
those is that the amendment I'm going to
withdraw
it all right this is
1583 uh next represent recogniz
representative Emer thank you Mr chair
relative to the per pupil cost of an
opportunity for an adequate education uh
there is an amendment on here it was my
Amendment and I'm withdrawing the
amendment uh so we don't need to worry
about it and so uh House Bill 1583 will
is submitted as passed by the house this
changed the adequacy to
$44 plus it had some uh language that
for fiscally challenged communities in
order to have grants for on a per
student
basis the basic bill is intact can you
recall the the uh fiscal note cost of
the
bill
Lander so the underlying House Bill 1583
the estimates that we have are
approximately $ 61.5 million in fiscal
year
25 $ 74.3 million in fiscal year
27 thank you very much further
discussion I'll I'll second it if you
need it all right so it's uh Emer Emer
seconded by
Edwards on the motion of ought to pass
on House Bill
1583 the amendment has been
withdrawn further
discussion seeing none
oh representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman these are huge numbers um on a
non-budget year and so I'm I'm not going
you represent he thank you Mr chair um
and I want to thank the chair of
division too for uh withdrawing the um
Amendment but um this uh 1583 is a
result of the subcommittee on education
it was a bipar committee made up of
Education finance and Ways and Means and
this was in response um to the courts
and it was basically we all came to
agreement on this particular Bill and it
was um to show our commitment to the
state and to school funding so I would
encourage the the body to vote Yes on
this bill it's an excellent Bill we all
agreed on it and bipartisan basement ba
basis it's been a long fight on this
Bill thank
you m and represent representative Emer
do you want a motion describe why you're
withdrawing your
Amendment uh yes the amendment
uh was added at the time we were under
Court recommendation to increase
adequacy uh on conal and also the ran
decision which had excess swept staying
with return to the state instead of
staying in the
communities what this what the amendment
did was kind of do a wraparound on conal
and Rand in order to please the wishes
of the Court uh but subsequently there
have been stays on both of those
judgments so the amendment is not
necessary at this time thank
you further discussion represent hle and
then representative string thank you Mr
chair um given that education funding as
a whole is being looked at by our
Supreme Court given that although this
is a small portion and it directly
impacts our local towns because they
fund the difference especially in
Special Ed I do think we should figure
out and wait um on passing any Bill
relative to education funding until we
get to a point where we understand what
the base adequacy is by the Supreme
Court because that might impact our
decision and with a 60 plus million
dollar perear price tag we should um
probably hold on to this bill represent
Stringham and then represent Edwards
well F first of all I I I appreciate um
with conil and uh Rand hanging over us
that uh you had the courage to put
something forward it's very hard to put
forward a bill that would increase um uh
public education by 500 million a year I
do agree with you that uh um we don't
need it at this at this time and support
the decision to withdraw that even
though that's not what we're voting um
uh in particular I feel that way because
uh this bill has uh uh been thoroughly
vetted meets a critical need and we need
to move forward on on um
1583 uh but the issues that uh that you
brought up in your bill eventually have
to be addressed by the
legislature um you know parts of our
state have been suffering from uh
outright depression for 30 years and and
the uh education funding formula is a
big part of that uh so uh to the extent
that conil and ran to become law that
forces us to to address those issues uh
but it's still good Economic Policy as
well as education policy uh to keep that
high in our thoughts uh that being said
1583 is not the place to do it so um I
will support 1583 as good law going
forward and thank you representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I'm I'm
very happy that the uh the other
Amendment had been withdrawn I I don't
think I could ever support the
legislature giving up the power of the
purse and deferring to a Judicial decree
on the amount of money being spent I
think that's one of the that is the key
thing we're here for is to determine the
spending of the people we represent so
I'm I'm glad that's behind us and uh
I'll I'll be voting for the uh
underlying Bill thank you it's also I
think worthy to note that in
2023 the legislature sent aund
million uh break back to the to the
municipalities 100 million reduction and
swept hoping to see reduction in
people's property taxes did anybody see
a
reduction so the idea to send a lot of
money back to the towns to reduce the
taxes does not seem to be a successful
idea they will use it
up representative luno did you have a
comment yeah thank you very much Mr
chair so this bill 1583 and and the next
one
1656 both um uh would direct U uh
precious State uh fund fing to our most
um um underserved communities the ones
that have the most challenging times of
raising raising money to support their
schools even with especially High
property taxes when um when I go around
knocking on doors during campaign season
the first thing that I hear from uh from
voters is what are you doing about
school funding what are you doing about
my property taxes this bill and the next
bill uh address those two things head on
and um and I hope this committee will
support both thank you and I'm glad
you're here to report what happened in
the education Committee in case we need
that input thank you all right so the
motion now before
us on uh House Bill 1583 is ought to
pass represented by representative Emer
or representative Petri represent
seconded by representative emeric is
that
correct I think it Ed em em Edwards Emer
Edwards
okay all right motion is ought to pass
on House Bill 1583 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion of ought to
pass on that Bill thank you Mr chairman
representative
Mooney
yes representative Maguire
no representative Petri votes
no representative uh em
no representative Edwards
yes representative Bean
no representative Sweeney
no represent camell
no represent papichi Muller
yes represent lman yes representative
Lane yes representative luno yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative torski yes representative
haken Phils
yes represent Stringham
yes representa grassy yes representative
priest yes representative Alexander
no
and representative
wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is
18-7 in favor of the
motion all right the motion passes goes
on the regular
calendar who will write The Minority
Report Mr chair I'll write the minority
rep represent for the minority and
that's not to pass
it interim study
um Mr pet or representative Petri
interim study for the minority motion
you all
right representative
Emer House Bill 1656 relative to
adequate education grant amounts for
pupils receiving special education
amendment
what what this bill does is another one
that came out of the joint special
committee uh that included Finance
education and ways and
means uh what it does is it takes
special needs and divides it up into
three different categories and three
different uh reimbursement
amounts
uh you can see you can see in the in the
amendment what those reimb those
are and this is something new because up
till now Ed special ad had gotten one
value for everybody and what this says
it's based on your needs and the number
of hours you need it for week
depend defines which level of
compensation the School
receives thank you and was
representative Emer seconded by
representative Petri on the
amendment everyone understand the
amendment are there any questions
representative tki thank you Mr chairman
I just want to clarify something the
amendment we were just handed is number
1211 and the amendment noted on the
sheet from the committee is 1511 so I
just want to make sure that we have the
correct appreciate it thank you 121 it's
correct corre yes that's the one we have
before US Representative Heath thank you
Mr chair I just wanted wanted to um let
um chair Emer know that I too will be
proposing an amendment thank you we have
a second amendment all right let's let's
see is everyone uh ready for a show of
hands on Amendment
all right looks like 13-
12 okay
and we now have an amendment from
representative Heath and representative
Heath has recognized to explain the
amendment thank you Mr chair um during
the um subcommittee the special
subcommittee um on um education funding
at the point in time that we discussed
special education funding we determined
that we had three categories and we
determined an amount of $
34,35 I'm sorry 34
m34 th000
$132 um the additional amount school
districts have encountered
extraordinarily high costs um the
categories I think will help but we need
to think about the costs that are
associated and the high cost so this
what my Amendment does it increases the
amount of the amendment to 35,000 and
increases each of the categories the um
uh Department was not able to um fund
each individual category at this time
but I would like to propose um the
amount of
$35,000 um for to go to districts for
special education thank you very much I
think that's 35 million I'm sorry 35
million thank you that makes more sense
a lot more sense Mr chairman just I can
I can put some values on this
yes what is what is the increase over
the the First Amendment the amend the
the my amendment is about
17,500 th000 uh the heath amendments
about 35
million
okay further discussion on the heath
Amendment who seconded that uh who
seconded that for the representative
Heath from committee members
represent Murray represent seconds
representative luno for a question thank
thank you very much no just a a comment
on the the heath Amendment the heath
Amendment does uh properly document the
um the vote of the special subcommittee
on school funding um that received by
partisan support and um and it is it is
absolutely you know consistent with what
the uh what the Committees what the
subcommittee's intent was for uh for
House Bill uh 16 56 again with B strong
bipartisan support and uh and this this
is uh is money that would uh would you
know address some of the highest need
students in every District all across
the state so it would uh would benefit
um uh benefit taxpayers uh throughout
the granite state and I hope the uh the
committee would uh would support this um
this amendment thank
you represent hacken Phillips thank you
Mr chair I just wanted to add the
technical note that this am mment does
honor the same
um correction in the previous amendment
that was offered and that um when the
special education numbers are taken in
October every year there are additional
students who fall into the category but
are not accounted for at the time of the
count that are you know attending school
later in the year and those costs do
accumulate to the school districts this
bill ALS or this amendment also accounts
for those additional students and that's
where the additional need is really seen
is that you know there are cases when
special ed students move into districts
after the admr is taken in
October and so it's really critical to
you know to make sure that we're
actually addressing the need as it is in
reality instead of you know the Frozen
moment of time that is taken in October
so I would urge the committee to support
those districts in supporting those
students thank
you that that's on my Amendment as
well
representa hle thank you Mr chair um
question this is 17 million versus 35
million per year correct
correct um and I think my next question
is for the LBA if I can I think we
increased um total spending from the
state significantly in hb1 and hb2 last
year can one of you give an estimate to
the nearest I don't know $20 million how
much we increased spending last year for
education
ballpark I'd have to look back I can
remember budget estimates but those
aren't what the actuals ended up being
for 24 and the new 25 estimates so I can
get those to you I just don't have those
off hand here okay is the 620 followup
follow is the 626 23 Amendment sorry um
summary that's on the LBA website the
current one was that the mo most recent
for Education cost or sorry increases in
spending cuz I'm seeing a 600 million
right total calculated education grant
and I'm just wondering if that was the
final number I don't know which document
you're referring to specifically I can
okay so to get to what you're all right
we'll give you a moment to try to find
that
for
representative
McGuire yes thank you Mr chairman the
numbers we've just been quoted can't
possibly be correct so um we've heard
that the heath Amendment cost 35 million
a year and the Emer Amendment costs
$175 million a year 17 A5 is half of
35 but none of the numbers the dollar
amounts in these bills is half in the
Emer Amendment of the of the numbers in
the heath Amendment so if the heath
amendment is actually 35 million the
Emer Amendment must be closer to 25 or
some number like that or if the Emer
amendment is actually 17 A5 than the
heath Amendment might be might be 25
million or something like that but but
these just don't add up yeah good catch
the the numbers in in one Amendment and
not half those in the other
soal so the grand total can't possibly
be half right so correct Mr chair if I
could just clarify the this is one
component of an education funding
formula with many components uh I will
say there's some netting going on here
in both examples with the hold harmless
that's in current law so with the heath
amendment that would take a big
out of the hold harmless so it's not
going to be a dollar for dooll okay
exercise as representative Maguire
suggested thank you all right um did you
ever find the totals yes we
added represent whole thank you um so it
looks like we went from um 962 million
to 1,000 sorry 1 b40 million and in 2024
and 1 bli 53 million so roughly 80
million in one year and 90 million in
another for a total of
170 we just added in the prior Bill
we've talked about 60 million above and
beyond what we did in the budget cycle
and we're now talking about potentially
another 35 I'm having trouble adding
another 100 million after we just did
that for each almost each year in the
last budget cycle this is a budget item
this is not necessarily something that
budget okay
represent Heath thank you Mr chair I
just would like to add that um in the
numbers for children with disabilities
the count includes the children that we
have in charter schools as well so the
costs while seemingly High cover great
expenses and we've seen the levels of
disabilities for children across the
state increase and the costs are high
and I think for our school districts
this is one of the benefits that we can
provide for them but again the charter
schools who have children that have
children with disabilities that cost is
covered by the local school district so
that's why I think it's important that
we look at the costs associated with for
our children with disabilities thank you
much thank you very much well we still
have the law that the school district
has to pay three and a half times the
average cost and if and then above that
it goes to 80% State and above 10 times
the average cost the state pays at all
so it it isn't as if there isn't already
some help in the formulas we have on
education assistance so even though
we've gone up in these amounts there
still is a great deal of money paid by
the state on all special ed costs and I
think that should be pointed out thank
you further discussion on this on this
amendment all right the heath Amendment
is
1327 without objection we'll adopt it by
opposed
13 somebody Miss 12 was 12 12 12 was it
first one 12 then 13 right correct
that's what I thought all right the
motion is
defeated all right so now the uh
amendment is
defeated now the motion before us is
ought to pass on House Bill 1656 as
amended
by amendment number
discussion all
right that em Petri and that was Emer
Petri on that Amendment cler will call a
roll on the motion of ought to pass as
1211 thank you Mr
chairman represent
Mooney
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle is this on adoption of the amendment
this pass amended Opa Opa
no represent Sweeney
yes represent Camrose yes represent
papovich Muller yes represent walner
no represent Lehman
yes represent
Lane
no represent luno no
represent of Heath
yes represent of Murray
yes represent Vil yes represent Tori
yes represent haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassy yes represent priest yes
representative Alexander yes
Mr chairman the vote is 21 to4 that that
correct and uh graac you'll be writing
the report yes and represent Heath he'll
minority and's what's the motion on the
minority
what's
yeah what's what's you're going to write
the minority
rep no you you voted yes okay who voted
minority I did all right so you will be
writing it okay and what what's the and
what will be the
the on on the other
Amendment
okay
we got an amendment yet for
318 okay we'll return back to house bill
Amendment
the
okay represent Lehman is recognized and
us thank thank you Mr
chairman how's excuse me how Bill 13 I'm
sorry
318 relative to bail Commissioners and
making Appropriations to the judicial
branch um I was going to recognize
representative Maguire the um initial
Amendment we were going to consider was
drafted under representative Maguire's
name earlier but there is an amendment
drafted under my name which is U
amendment number
1404 and someone like to Second
Sweeny motion so which which one are you
moving we're going to I'm going to move
1404 that's the uh the only change
between the two the one we had earlier
was the magistrate number originally you
called recall Mr chairman we had five
magistrates coming out of the division
this amendment brings that number up to
magistrates okay and that's motion by
representative
lean second
Sweeny and I believe there is discussion
Mr chairman representative Maguire
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman and Mr chairman uh could we
hand out this I I this is a complicated
bill because it's it's from three or
four depending on how you count
different bills that we received we've
combined them all into a single bill to
make it easier to read and um easier to
understand and we don't yet have a
fiscal note for it so I did a little you
know handout here that that will explain
the the the numbers involved
um I mean these are not division 2 scale
of
numbers these are our little tiny
division one size numbers but
anyway all right so I'll wait till
one
okay thank you for pointing out the
differences yes
so so what this bill does the the all of
these bills are about bail and and also
including um training of Judges so
um the uh criminal justice committee
mostly has and I though I guess some
came from the Judiciary Committee but
anyways they they've proposed a fair
number of changes to the way baale is um
is determined and um who
what happens to people when they're out
on bail and so on so I'll just go down
the list of the money these are all the
money items number one is they're
proposing hiring a new category of
Judiciary employee called a magistrate
there aren't any magistrates right now
you can think of a magistrate as a kind
of a junior judge it can do a magistrate
can do some things that a judge can do
but not not everything can't conduct
trials but can um
uh decide on bail can put out search
warrants and and some other things that
that are in the bill um the cost of the
magistrate is is assumed to be
$156,000 annually each the the the main
bone of contention between the majority
and the minority on this bill is the
number of magistrates the original bills
called for 15 magistrates which would
have been an annual cost of 2.3 million
uh um the amendment I I um in front of
us the amendment in front of us right
now is the 1.6 million annual cost and
what I would prefer is the um
$800,000 annual cost all right uh we
I'll get back to that in a moment so um
then we have the bail information system
currently there's no way when when
police officer arrests someone for them
to know what whether or not this person
is already out on bail on some other
charge and so uh this is a one-time 1.7
million to upgrade the computer systems
of both the Judiciary and the department
of safety and there will be some some
annual maintenance fees probably in the
100,000 200,000 sort of range um we
don't know what that is but it's mostly
this one-time fee then there's bail
Commissioners So
currently um bail is
determined um primarily by bail
Commissioners who are semi volunteers
there's 95 of them around the state they
receive for their work uh they they go
out when someone is arrested and they
want to talk to a bail commissioner they
go out in the middle of the night on
weekends whenever to the police station
where the person is being held they
speak with the with the accused they
determine if there's going to be bail
and what the conditions might be and
they are paid a $40 fee by the
accused um this these amendments
increase that $40 fee to
$60 and it also in the case where the
accused is Indigent it doesn't pay the
$40 or the
$60 um that would be paid for by the
state um and
so they would be guaranteed to get the
money when right now many of them um
don't get paid on all cases and so we we
I would estimate and this is really just
a guess that there might be 4,000 annual
Indigent cases so times $60 that's uh an
extra
$240,000
annually all right um the we had a bill
house bill
one5 which had the Judiciary hire a
training coordinator and it required uh
judges to take certain amounts of annual
training and other Judiciary employees
so that that bill has been included in
House Bill
and um so so the and that training
coordinator is given is charged with
doing training for the bail
Commissioners setting up a training
program for the bail Comm Commissioners
um and the magistrates and so that's an
annual cost of maybe 100,000 maybe a
little bit more for that
person um the the bills uh require that
people out on bail for serious crimes so
for for for a list certain crimes that
are that are very serious violent crimes
and so on that if they're out on bail
they must be monitored with ankle
bracelets um the original bills had the
courts doing that but that was turned
out to be unfeasible this the the courts
do not do pre-trial monitoring or they
don't have a pre-trial division some
states do that but in not in New
Hampshire in New Hampshire all the
pre-trial uh monitoring and and um
supervision is done by counties so this
these amendments move the responsibility
for ankle bracelets to counties and
allow them to charge the accused which
is what they do some County four
counties already do this six counties
don't but they they all charge the
accused who's out on bail the cost of
the ankle bracelets and so we've
continued that so it appears to us like
there is no cost to it because it's
being paid by the accused and then
there's there's other aspects of these
bills that will cost money or save money
um so first of all
um the the cases where people will not
be allowed to be
bailed seems like it would go up a bit
because of this these this legislation
so therefore if more people are in jail
jail is more expensive than bail so
there might be more costs involved there
um
uh but then on the other hand maybe some
can who are currently in jail will be
let out with ankle bracelets ankle
bracelets cost less even if the person
is Indigent than putting somebody in
jail so there might be fewer people that
way and then there's the aspect that
magistrates will relieve some of the
work done by judges and so therefore
maybe cases would be processed faster
and and if the somebody's case somebody
is in jail waiting on their case being
processed there might be less cost
although you know if they if the case
gets processed quicker and if the person
ends up not going to prison right but on
the other hand almost everybody who's
accused is found guilty later on in the
process so I'm not sure how big this
number will be but there's something
okay let's go back to magistrates so the
way these bills came to us um was that
that they changed certain serious crimes
those serious violent crimes can no
longer be um can no longer be bail
decisions can no longer be made by baale
Commissioners for those for those
classes of crimes we're talking about
rape or serious domestic IC violence or
obviously murder nobody gets bailed for
anyways but but for those serious crimes
only magistrates will be able to or
judges can make those decisions and so
the the original
bills sort of theorized that that 15
magistrates could sort of blanket the
state and make those
decisions sort of on weekends and so on
one other thing these bills do by the
way is currently if somebody's arrested
on a weekend and they don't see a bail
commissioner they can sit in jail for a
few days because until a judge until
it's a weekday and then they see a judge
who makes the bail decision but but
these bills require that bail decisions
be made within 24 hours um so therefore
that's why they want to hire magistrates
to make make those decisions on weekends
ja Commissioners work all the time 24
hours so anyways um but the numbers in
my mind don't
justify um the higher numbers of
magistrates the numbers of cases
that um magistrates are required to
decide based on these bills is about
1,400 cases a year so that means it's
roughly 30 cases a week so if you have
five magistrates they're only doing
roughly six cases a week all right and
and each so that's like one day's worth
of work right and the other four days
worth of work can still be used to
improve the situation with judges and so
on so in my mind only five are
Justified um some people some of us
think maybe we should simply make bail
Commissioners better and not have any
magistrates others want higher numbers
so the other the other compromise is 10
so that's where we stand and I'm happy
to answer questions thank you questions
for representative
Maguire being none so I have that
uh Amendment
1404 is moved by representative Lehman
seconded by representative Sweeney is
there any further discussion on that
amendment can we do this by a show of
hands all in favor raise your hand on
Amendment
1404 I think I see 23 pants down
opposed all right two
opposed oh I miss who did I miss all
right
22-3
okay so now the motion before us is
ought to pass as amended for House Bill
318 as amended by amendment number
motion representative Maguire did turned
on your light did you have F I'm sorry
I'm ready to vote okay thank you for
seeing no further discussion the clerk
will call the role on the motion of
house Bill 318 ought to pass as amended
by amendment number 4
1404 motion of ought to pass as amended
thank you Mr chairman representative
Mooney yes representative Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative EMR yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes
represent Sweeny yes represent Campell
no represent POA V Muller
yes representative walner yes
representative Lehman
yes representative Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative eel
yes representative lski yes represent
hen Phillips yes represent Stringham yes
represent grassy yes representative
priest yes representative Alexander
yes representative uh Wilder
yes Mr chair the vote is 24 to1 in favor
of the
motion all right representative leasman
report okay and is there a minority
report okay no
minority
you all right we finished with division
one bills we next going to recognize
representative Edwards for the division
three bills on the second
page uh thank you Mr chair we've got uh
four bills here today um first one up is
uh uh
1363 I would look to uh representative
Mooney to make a
motion thank you Mr chair Mr chair I
would move itl on House Bill
itl I'd like to speak a little to that
Mr chair I recognize this um this the
underlying bill would allow members of
the general court and their family to
receive um an employee benefit labeled
the employee assistance program uh there
was no debate really in the division
three about the quality and the
importance of EAP programs for uh
employees for corporate corporations
invest in these programs because they
make a lot of sense issue isn't about
the program um in in in my
instance uh I oppose
1363 primarily because it would go into
effect um in um the next term and I
think a lot of us would be asked to vote
for a bill that we can kind of forecast
whether or not will benefit personally
from it and then and then the other
bigger thing
though you want to Second this oh didn't
I second I meant to Second it yes yes
sir um and then the the bigger issue is
um our compensation is laid out in um
the Constitution it's $100 a year this
would be a new benefit for which members
would not be expected to pay anything
themselves into the program this would
all come from a increase in the
speaker's budget uh and while there are
other examples like dental insurance and
health insurance General Court members
can pay for those uh are programs that
the U member pays for themselves um so
it it's it's it's different in that case
so for so for those reasons uh I would
uh ask people to support um
representative Mooney's itl
recommendation representative tki thank
you very much Mr
chairman I support uh House Bill
1363 um and I do have an amendment if
this uh motion is unsuccessful that will
address the concerns that um
representative Edwards just pointed out
um the EAP program provides confidential
assistance on issues that affect our
overall overall well-being by providing
referrals and support to such issues
like emotional health Financial concerns
family challenges Health Management
substance misuse gambling and more
providing access to the EAP would
encourage our overall well-being as
legislators to better serve our
constituents and would be a valuable
tool for the speaker's office the Senate
President the leadership uh caucus
leadership as they often attempt to
assist legislators as they struggle with
challenges that affect our ability to do
our work um my Amendment if I would be
able to introduce it when we get to that
point addresses the concerns that were
just outlined um it clarifies who
qualifies it includes language that the
legislators are not considered employees
um that there should not be any
unintended
consequences and it actually pushes the
effective date out to
2027 which is clear that we would not be
adding any kind of benefit as there are
two elections between now and then and
none of us really know what the
situation will be um in 2027 and who
will be
returning um supporters of this bill
believe that it's simply an expansion of
our already existing wellness program
that the general court has um that
really is embodied in our state house
nurse um we already have access to such
things as health education and guidance
for our well-being um and I'd like to
point everyone's attention to the email
that came out from the speaker's office
the newsletter just this weekend which
announced health screening day scheduled
on April 30th um it's described the
event is described
like this during the event you will have
the opportunity to have your blood
pressure checked assess your balance
learn Hands-On only CPR AED operation
and stop the bleed techniques in
addition you can receive stress
reduction tips obtain nutritional
counseling enjoy chair massages and
information on yoga meditation and raike
we encourage you to take advantage of
this valuable opportunity to prioritize
your health and well-being
so I think this bill just is a direct
extension of health screening day as the
speaker has scheduled with our state
house nurse um by preventing sickness
and crisis and allowing us to do our
work I don't see this bill as
compensation in any such way for us as
legislators finally the fiscal note
while it was not revised for my
Amendment um it's my understanding this
bill would cost about $188,000 a year
and the legislative branch has stated
that it can absorb this cost within the
existing
appropriation therefore I um encourage
everyone to vote no on the itl so that
we can um look at my Amendment and
promote Wellness as a priority for all
of us to be able to serve our
constituents better thank
you representa Stringham is recognized
yes thank you Mr chair um you know I I
felt like the big concern about this is
you know the term employee and that the
uh those of us serving in the
legislatures are not employees and we're
not but the legislature is a Workforce
and the kind of programs that the
speaker has put forward uh for wellness
day and a program like this uh would
would all serve the state of New
Hampshire well at virtually no money I
urge my colleagues uh to turn down the
itl motion and listen to representative
to toki's uh Amendment uh and move
forward from there thank you represent
PRI thank you Mr uh chairman uh I will
also be opposing the itl bill and
will'll be supporting the amendment that
will be offered up by the
representative um which is regarding the
term date of this bill um
I did see on a firsthand basis the value
of this program to my employees while I
was the executive director for the
Southern New Hampshire Planning
Commission and I saw that the benefits
of this program clearly
outweighed the minimal cost that will be
provided that will be spent for its
costs and so I would urge you all to
reconsider and vote down the itl and
vote for the amendment that will be
offered and support this uh Bill thank
you representative Edwards this is
really just a clarification question for
representative tki is is is the
amendment that you're uh preparing to
introduce exactly the same as the one we
talked about in committee or are there
are some minor variations between the
committee version and this
version we had looked at two different
amendments um regarding this bill one
was from you which pushed the date out
10 years um and then the other one was
um the one that I would propose which
addresses the three concerns that you
had so it's the same one thank you for
that further discussion representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman so I have
a possibly relevant personal experience
because I buy the uh um the health and
the dental myself and um back in January
I got an email
saying if you sign up for this diet
program we'll send you a free scale and
Fitbit and uh at no cost to you right
and it's from this program from from
this health thing and so I did okay and
so now here I am
bill all right for the program and and
so I called them up and I said you sent
me an email saying no cost to you and
and so they said okay we'll take care of
it and um so then a few weeks later I
got another bill where they say we cover
like $30 and your part's $150
[Laughter]
so I'm about to make a new phone call
tomorrow maybe on on that but so we
don't seem to get all of these these
ancillary things and I don't know if
anybody could say whether this
particular program I I do know that
employees get like gym memberships and
other things so is that all included in
what what we're talking about here or or
not I don't know represent tki may know
thank you Mr chairman no not at all this
is
very similar to um referrals say
representative Maguire you went um were
in some kind of Crisis let's say you
found out um you know
you were diagnosed with diabetes
unexpected you're struggling to put it
all together get the education materials
you need get the dietary nutrition
counseling you need you could go to the
EAP program and they would have a number
of referrals that could direct you to
the right resources to help you get
through that crisis moment in your life
as you're trying to absorb all that and
be able to then serve your constituents
not miss a day in session and show up
and have the necessary um materials that
you need it's not reimbursing any gym
memberships it's not any free running
shoes it's not fitbits this is all
referrals representa
Edwards I I would agree with everything
representative tki just said but I would
also say that like any benefit program
this is subject to modification in the
future and that modification would be
done by the people who control the state
employee EAP program and the general
court would already be automatically
tied to it so so I I I still oppose uh
the amendment
further
discussion the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1363 if there's no further discussion
the clerk will call the rooll on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative Mooney
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
represent of bean yes represent of hole
yes represent of Sweeney yes represent
of Campell yes represent papich Muller
yes representa walner
no representative Lehman no
representative Lane no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
representa Murray no representa evil no
represent torki no representative hen
Phillips no representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
Priest
No representative Alexander yes
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 13 to 12 in favor of the
amendment to kill the bill the it motion
to kill itl itl itl motion passes will
there be a minority there most
definitely will thank you representative
tki will write the
minority and what will the the motion
will be it will be ought to pass as
amended
okay and the majority report will
be I'll write that represent
Edwards
13 okay representative
Edwards uh 15 uh 88 uh relative to court
jurisdiction over persons receiving
special education uh I there on the on
the sheet here there are four X's for
the amendment so I think we're getting a
fresh
Amendment uh I I think is what we ended
up doing was uh we discussed a written
document that was an amendment during
division three uh we debated it a little
bit and we um agreed to allow the LBA to
work with OS to find T tune this um and
as I understand it this has come back
identical to what the division agreed to
uh it spends a sum of uh $3
million it is uh appropriate for us to
uh accept because um well I guess I
guess I should have a motion at this
point or we should have a motion to
before we continue to debate
it pres Edwards moves Amendment 1391
second
Muller further discussion representative
Edwards so just to complete that thought
um and uh rep representative Mooney did
some additional uh homework into this on
behalf of the committee and uh I I think
the summary of what she came up with is
that uh the the law around the age of
eligibility uh has been set in other
laws that are already on the books and
that when we considered postponing the
start of this uh Bill the effective date
of the bill till later what we were told
in in testimony was it really didn't
matter because with the laws already in
place we were going to still be spending
the same amount of money so what this
amendment and this bill does is it is it
gets our actual uh
uh government aligned across all the
Departments using the same eligibility
date and it also puts the the
appropriation for it uh on top of the
table instead of um circumventing and
being backfilled so I I would uh I would
hope that U the U committee would
1588 a new one just got handed out it's
it's to House Bill 1588 and the
amendment seeing
none is it acceptable for a show of
hands all in favor of adopting Amendment
I see 25 hands down any opposition
that's
unanimous okay we have down here that uh
the motion was tersi seconded by priest
is that still
old
okay so the motion before us now is
ought to pass as
amended by house by Senate by ought to
pass as amended House Bill 1588 as
amended by
1391 any further discussion on that
motion ought to pass as amended seeing
none the clerk will call the role on
that on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative Mooney
yes representa Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeny yes
representative camell yes representative
pich Muller yes representative walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative Lane yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes represent torski yes was that a
no did did I hear that correctly no I
said yes oh I'm
sorry sometimes it sounds like yes and I
make sure representa hen Phillips
yes represent Stringham
yes represent grassy yes representative
priest yes yes representative Alexander
yes representative wer yes Mr chairman
the vote is 25 to zero in favor of the
motion okay okay and representative
tersi will write the report I think
representative Mooney made the original
motion all right I mean am I wrong
representative Mooney will write the
report yeah I'll do
it you do oh all right there you go well
it is it is unlikely not to have a
debate so if you have if if one of you
has a a a pi that may be all that's
required and likely nothing
okay well no if if it goes down you know
quite often we've seen things with this
sort of vote where the speaker just
moves ahead and just calls for the vote
Voice vote so I expect with as many
bills that will be on the calendar from
this committee that he'll be going
through them as quickly as he can which
is I I say again if we can just do pis
on some of these uh what when you want
to have more than that please send me a
message that you want more than a pi so
we'll be ready for it on both sides okay
so representative priest for the
committee report
okay
PR and like I said if you have a good Pi
you may not get to use it but you you
might be called
on representative
Edwards uh thank you um I would I'd like
to just he house bill
1598 um I think this is going to aim
towards an
otpa uh there's a um I believe a
representative walner Amendment
13 or excuse me
1183 and uh and representative walner we
didn't rehearse this I I suspect you're
Amendment
it all right I'll wait till everybody
has an
amendment
was
revised so representative walner
whichever Amendment version you care to
138h and um what this bill deals with is
that when children go into
custody with the Department of Health
and Human Services If the
child has Social Security
Disability or they have a Social
Security um payment because a um a
parent has died
while they are in custody of the state
the state takes that um
payment and uses it um and well
basically puts it into the general fund
and uses it in um child welfare issues
um what this
does the department
have it was it got complicated with the
Department
around some of
the Social Security laws and the state
laws and so this is happening in many
many states across the country that um
we are not they are not um taking the
the payments from from the children
instead they're keeping them putting
them aside for the children's use um
after they get out of um foster care or
residential
care what we decided to do was end up
with a consultant that the department
would be able to hire it would um cost
$150,000 to have the consultant on board
um the consultant would be responsible
for looking at uh what this what kind of
ramifications this would have on State
budget um the report would recommend U
budget proposals for the bium of
27 uh
2027 and we would be looking for a
consultant who has knowledge in this
area especially in the area of Social
Benefits further discussion represent
hle
thank you Mr chair um I believe Mr
Ripple has another amendment as well
like 1365
copies um to at
least put it on the floor for
discussion everything the represented
from conquered said is true it does the
same thing it just manages the
accounting slightly different and my
biggest concern and we've talked about
this um extensively during the
committee was depending on how we fund
this position I don't want it to become
the basis for the future budget in
future terms that extra
$150,000 um the workload would continue
through the end of the year for the
report would continue during the
discussions and dialogues of
implementing this during the budget
season but I don't want to just
arbitrarily grow the budget by
$150,000 so this another amendment funds
the position through an alternate means
by reducing the um general fund laps so
that it doesn't actually increase the
spending and the difference between the
two is this one would actually allow for
up to $200,000 instead of the
150 but it doesn't mandate it be spent
on this allowing the department to
says F further discussion quick question
did you want me to hand that Amendment
out no I think we have another am mment
before us so we'll vote on that before
second who seconded representative W
Mooney
okay representor Maguire uh thank you Mr
chairman I have a question how much
Social Security money is is in dispute
here and and would this bill cause that
to go away or is it just just to make a
decision sort of representa that that's
an excellent question and one of the
questions that we have been looking for
an answer to for a while and that's one
of the things that the consultant would
help the department U figure this out
and also the num we never were really
able to um pin down the actual number of
children
that the state is caring for who have
social security disability either
because the child's disability these are
these are children who
are very seriously disabled it's not
easy to get Social Security Disability
so these are children who are going to
have a lifetime of of very um heavy
expenses so helping keep this money for
their use and to take care of their
special needs um rather than go into the
general fund is really the the intent of
the bill and what other states are doing
at anybody
else representative Edwards um thank you
Mr chair I I I appreciate the work that
representative walner put in on this uh
the uh the division three uh discussion
on this initially we were talking about
200,000 and and there was a consensus at
150 so she included that amount and and
uh we talked about it offline and this
is this is exactly what I was hoping
she'd bring forward so I I will be
voting for this
amendment okay have an amendment before
us
1308 and if there's no further
discussion let's vote on that by a show
of hands all in
favor
I see
25 all right the motion is
adopted all right for that Amendment now
I will recognize representative Hull if
amendment thank you Mr chairman yeah I
think it's worthwhile handing out
Amendment 1316 H um and it really is was
intended to address not increas ing the
bium by the $150,000 per year I don't
want to see that one contract be lumped
into the Baseline costs as they plan to
budget
representative Hull is recognized to
explain his
Amendment thank you Mr chairman um all
this amendment does is fund the same
position via different meth mechanism
and at a slightly different amount it
allows for up to $200,000 in line 17 and
18 to be used for funding this
contractual position and then for where
the money comes it reduces the required
laps from the Department from 23.4
million down to 23.2 million in line
26 it doesn't require that they spend
the full
$200,000 um but because it is funded the
way it's funded they could find a
position for $40,000 and use the excess
money to for other other things within
the department and it doesn't increase
our spending going into the following um
bium you have more text in your
Amendment than was in the previous one
can you explain the
difference
so this was the original request that we
Maguire I think I could probably explain
I think House Bill one probably has a
back of the budget kind of
reduction lapse requirement for HHS so
this is editing that part so it's copied
that paragraph out of house build
right if I can section two has to deal
with how to appropriate the funding okay
as opposed to line 17 through 20 um
this identifies at 17 through 20 are
that we're going to allow them to have
$200,000 and then lines 24 through the
end have to do with how this is dealt
with in terms of where right the budget
this the chapter
law further
discussion representative Emer thank you
Mr
chairman I I appreciate the creativity
of this uh Amendment because it's kind
of like it's very Innovative but that's
my
concern that this is very Innovative and
I don't know if accounting is going to
be all thrilled about it quite honestly
because what we're doing is we're we're
paying we're paying for this out of a
negative reduction of a lapse it's like
my head spinning so I don't I'm not
going to support this just because I
discussion seeing
none are you ready to adopt this
amendment by a show of hands all in
hand all
opposed all right the motion is the
amendment is not adopted what's the
C it was like
um
yeah all right motion now before us is
ought to pass as amended House Bill
1308 further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call a rooll on that motion
Mller and it's uh the motion is by
Mooney very good thank you Mr
chairman representating Mooney
yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
papovich mull yes representative walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes represent torki
yes representative haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
represent grassy yes representative
priest yes represent Alexander yes
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 25 to Z in favor of the motion
okay again um likely to only need a u a
pi if anything
so since it spends money it can't go on
consent in in the committee report um I
Edwards uh thank you last but not least
uh this ought to be an easy one HB
1669 relative to restricting data
sharing through the state immunization
uh registry uh there was an amendment on
this um the amendment was oh so I'll
I'll I'll wait for a
motion
okay okay Mr chairman I would move ought
to pass with
Amendment right representative Mooney
moves on
good and the amendment before us
is
recognized thank you Mr chairman looks
like an amendment has just been
distributed on House Bill 1669
representative hle I see your name at
the top would you care to go through
that sure um this bill came to us um
with a higher expense and this amendment
reduces it to the necessary cost to
second article sorry part 1 Article 2 B
constitution further discussion
represent Edwards uh thank you Mr chair
I I just want to uh thank representative
Lyon since she's here uh she worked on
the a policy committee on this bill and
then uh she came to us for a bunch of
substitutions and helped us understand
this amendment better and I I support uh
representative H's
um motion and I just wanted to thank
work
okay further discussion on amendment
number
1274 seeing none we adopt it by a show
of hands all in favor of adopting
hand
looks looks unanimous any oos
nothing
okay motion before us is ought to pass
House Bill
1669 as amended by amendment number
1274 further discussion on that
motion seeing none the clerk will call
that follow a roll on that motion of
ought to pass as
amended very good thank you Mr chairman
uh representative Mooney
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
POI meller yes representative walner yes
representative Lehman yes representative
Lane yes representative luno yes
represent of Heath yes represent Murray
yes represent evil yes represent torki
yes represent
stringam yes
represent skipped one representative
haken Phillips I'm sorry it's okay too
fast I vote yes thank you representative
grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
Alexander
yes representative wer yes Mr chairman
the V is 25 toer in favor of the motion
okay again uh not likely to need an
extensive
report uh who do we have down for the
needed I want to see if representative
hle wants to write it since it's his
Amendment sure all right again and then
be ready for the pi yeah probably that's
all you'll need if any I'm sure that the
uh speaker will go through this on a
Voice vote without without any debate um
so uh there's a lot of reports both
minority and majority I'm not going to
hang around today waiting till I get
them all if you send them to me in email
please send them also to Janet
Clayman and send and both Janet Clayman
and I and I think you all know the
emails to write them to
um so we're not going to meet this
Thursday so we've got a little over a
week to get ready
for
the calendar which will be a at a at a
deadline for crossover and so uh please
get
these these U reports in no later than
tomorrow we don't have anything on the
schedule for tomorrow or Thursday or
Friday so lots of times to think about
what we're going to have on before us on
the 11th it will be a very lengthy day I
don't know how many these are all going
to be second committee bills which
there's still quite a number other than
our approximately 40 bills maybe it's 38
by now but anyway um be ready for a long
day and uh hopefully short if we don't
have just piis don't go into a lengthy
discussion the history will show that it
doesn't help you pass the Bill make a
few piffy
points and leave it at that represent
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I I I just
want to point out that um I I'll be out
of state all next week and
representative Mooney will be the acting
chair and handle the floor stuff on the
I won't be
there putting us in
Peril I thought I was being smart
judging it after U crossover well all
right so she'll be able to handle the
flow work I know that Mr chairman do you
know how many Senate bills are likely
headed our way at all I haven't seen a
report at this point when I have it I'll
send it out in an
email Mr chair can I I just ask that the
Democrats meet in division two room
right now yeah just for a few minutes
very good thank you so yeah let's keep
keep the reports brief uh what the
speech is brief the report can be
lengthier if if people read it um and I
appreciate all your work and enjoy the
rest of the week I'm I've heard some
rumors of a snowstorm has anybody heard
that doesn't does that coming tomorrow
or
Thursday all the way through
driving
for